Mississippi voir cette clinique
d'avortement comment il
fonctionne et c'est là que de la
♪ ♪ ♪
- Jackson, une ville paisible
en plein coeur du Mississippi.
Rien ne semble perturber
ses 150 000 habitants...
... à part cette petite clinique
rose.
"Vous serez jugé devant Dieu",
crie ce militant pro-vie
au médecin qui vient à peine
d'arriver à la seule clinique
d'avortement de l'État.
Les médecins viennent
d'autres États et se relaient;
la clinique n'a pas eu de
médecin régulier depuis 10 ans
pour des raisons de sécurité.
Un peu plus loin,
Basil Chisholm, un facteur
à la retraite, tient fermement
sa pancarte anti-avortement.
"Quand ils ont libéré les camps
de concentration, dit-il,
les gens disaient qu'ils ne
savaient pas. Les gens
Un peu plus loin,
Basil Chisholm, un facteur
à la retraite, tient fermement
sa pancarte anti-avortement.
"Quand ils ont libéré les camps
de concentration, dit-il,
les gens disaient qu'ils ne
savaient pas. Les gens
doivent savoir, ajoute-t-il,
qu'ils tuent des bébés ici."
♪ (corne) ♪
Chaque jour, c'est l'état
de siège devant cette clinique.
Les manifestants ne peuvent
franchir la frontière
du stationnement.
- So he will judge rapist,
he will judge murderer!
- Un va-et-vient continu.
Elles sont des dizaines
du Mississippi, mais aussi
du Texas, de la Louisiane,
venues se faire avorter.
Le nombre de patientes a presque
doublé, soit 300 par mois depuis
qu'il y a des restrictions
dans les autres États.
Escortées par des bénévoles,
comme AP, étudiante en médecine,
qui vient les soutenir
deux à trois fois par semaine
et servir de rempart entre elles
et les manifestants.
"Ils peuvent me crier dessus
toute la journée, dit-elle,
ça ne me dérange pas.
Par contre, je ne les laisserai
pas approcher nos patientes."
Cette clinique est au coeur
d'une bataille judiciaire aux
États-Unis et la Cour suprême
doit trancher.
Mary Ziegler a signé plusieurs
livres sur l'avortement aux
États-Unis. Les droits acquis
sont en train de s'étioler,
dit-elle.
"On a le droit de choisir de
se faire avorter aux États-Unis,
dit-elle, avant la viabilité
du foetus, c'est-à-dire entre 21
et 24 semaines, quand le foetus
ne peut survivre en dehors
de l'utérus."
"Mais pour défendre la loi du
Mississippi, dit-elle, la Cour
suprême devra dire que le droit
d'avorter peut être supprimé
même avant la viabilité du
foetus. Ça va être un changement
significatif dans la loi."
En attendant que la Cour
suprême tranche, la clinique,
elle, poursuit ses activités.
Darendra Hancock est bénévole
depuis neuf ans.
"Les lois sont de pire en pire,
dit-elle, et plus difficiles
à bloquer."
"Les militants pro-vie
sont plus déterminés que jamais,
dit-elle, surtout depuis 2016,
depuis Donald Trump, ils se
sentent plus puissants."
(cris)
Et tout les moyens sont bons.
Après la colère,
ce sont les prières.
(prêche en anglais)
La clinique fait jouer
de la musique pour étouffer
les sons de l'extérieur.
♪ ♪ ♪
Les militants apportent
à leur tour des haut-parleurs.
"On tient le coup, dit
Derandra, légèrement excédée,
il y a toujours des manifestants
qui harcèlent nos patientes."
"Certaines d'entre elles
pleurent", dit-elle.
Si la Cour surpême donne raison
au Mississippi et renverse
l'arrêt Roe contre Wade, c'est
le feu vert pour chaque État,
selon les experts, qui veulent
restreindre, voire interdire
l'accès à l'avortement.
Au moins 20 États sont sur
le qui-vive et attendent
la décision de la Cour suprême
avant d'agir.
"Eventuellement, dit-elle,
la Cour suprême va donner
le droit aux États d'agir
sur la question de avortement."
Et comme il y a 50 ans
devant cette Cour suprême,
les deux camps s'affrontent,
brandissant les mêmes pancartes
"La liberté des femmes et en
jeu", scandent les manifestants.
Une fois de plus, les deux
Amériques s'entredéchirent.
Et pour beaucoup, c'est aussi
la crédibilité de la Cour
suprême qui est en jeu.